what a season this gentleman just had
quite simply the greatest season any
quarterbacks ever had at the collegiate
level and he is widely expected to be
the first name we hear when it all goes
down and the it is the NFL Draft in Las
Vegas Nevada
courtesy of bolts 24 by Gatorade none
other than Jill burrow here on the Rich
Eisen show hi I'm thrilled to have you
here on this program yeah you bet man
what what got into you this year Joe
let's start with that lots of hard work
lots of hard work and I kind of knew it
was gonna happen I'd tried to express it
to the media in the offseason and they
kind of laughed it off and threw it to
the side but we knew we were we had
worked for this what's the work give me
the work that you said lots of hard work
well starting well started a long time
ago but this season started in January
after January 2nd after he beat UCF in
the Fiesta Bowl right and we got right
back to work we knew we knew we could do
this so we were in here we were in the
facility every Saturday throwing lifting
astra and everybody was doing it wasn't
just me and the receivers right and we
knew we knew we had the capability of
doing this and so when you said it
started a long time ago what do you mean
by that well I mean a national
championship is a culmination of a lot
of hard work for a lot of individuals
that come together as a team and so that
work started when you were in middle
school and decided you wanted to play
college football and so people that made
that decision like myself are in there
every Saturday from the time they were
13 years old so again you know I'm sure
you told this story quite a bit but you
know for a new audience that may not
know how many times do you think you
were told you can in your life a lot a
lot you know it started and I wanted to
go to a certain school coming out of
high school and they didn't want me and
and then you go to the to the school
that recruits you you don't get an
opportunity that that you felt you might
have deserved and then you know Coach o
gave me that opportunity LSU gave me
that opportunity and I just ran with it
so what did happen at Ohio State I'm
sorry the Ohio State what happened at
the Ohio State you you know there's a
lot of circumstances injuries
in battles you know just a lot of things
that you know I just wasn't meant to be
there and I still have a lot of love for
all the people there I was back there
last week saw the coaches that are still
there saw all my buddies that are still
on the team so this there's no bad blood
between us you know we're you still love
each other and stay in contact as well
well I gotta be honest with you Joe you
know I'm a Michigan guy and I have an
agenda to see if there is any bad blood
between you and I just so I could stir
it up find just a little slice of it and
stir it up
am I getting nothing on that I mean
there isn't anything to stir up really
there really isn't
other than the fact that you that didn't
play that's it yeah and that you have
played and you know and the highs in the
national championship writi Mutchler it
up what is it about coach oh I you got a
lot of people including him all choked
up when won the Heisman talking about a
towards Iran who's now gotten that
long-term contract what what what about
him is something that led to you being
in this position right now
I mean there was there weren't a lot of
people that wanted to give me the
opportunity it was a third year guy who
had played on almost 0 snaps coming off
a broken hand and he gave me the
opportunity I was looking for I wanted
to win a national championship that was
my goal coming into college and and he
gave me the opportunity to do that and
you know I've got an eleven eight and
six year old when they see him on the
screen that I think they think he's a
cartoonist they love him they can't get
enough but just kids see him and just
what what is he like when he's not in
front of a camera what you see is what
you get right he's not phony he you know
he told me all these things in
recruiting and everything came true what
like what I mean he said he said you
know the plan for for me to compete for
the job and try to win a starting job
and when the decision will be made and
everything played out the way he said it
would and then his plan for the program
winning a national championship in two
years with me at the helm came true as
well so he's you know this there's not a
lot of honesty in this industry and he's
an honest guy how many words did you
understand were the first time that he
spoke to the first the first year it was
tough you know when he gets excited he
gets his Cajun accent going and it's
tough to understand I need
closed-caption yeah
I don't know if even that can do it but
he know I got to got to understand a
little better the second year you start
to learn is his verbage and then some of
the swag that you have where did that
where does that come from I think you
just born with that I don't know it's
you know I think it starts in confidence
and confidence starts in preparation and
I pride myself in my preparation I think
I win the game on Tuesday Wednesday
Thursday with my film study and in
preparation and practice Joe burrow here
on the Rich Eisen show and it seems like
you can make every throw man I mean I'm
watching it I obviously I'm I pay more
attention to the pro game in terms of
week in week out looks like you can make
every throw you can drop it in you can
find a window you can lead a receiver
you can make sure receiver doesn't get
blown up where does that come from how
have you been able to do what makes Pro
ready kids so ready for the NFL I
couldn't always make all those throws
you know coming in college I was a work
in progress and I worked at it you know
that's really all I can say I wasn't you
know I wasn't this five-star guy with
this big arm 230 pounds runs a 404 I had
to work at it and I've I did I was in
like I said I worked harder than anybody
to get here so what are you gonna run to
be determined I don't know come on let's
see me a number what do you think you're
gonna run you know I think I could do it
on a good day and a 4-6 okay yeah so
you're gonna have a good day at the
combine let's see I hope so Oh oh my
gosh now let me get into this I am you
know I've been doing the combine on it
on NFL Network for like 12 13 years now
this is another moment for me right here
Joe nothing disappoints me greater than
to sit in a booth and have a prospect
like you stand in his pajamas
essentially on the field and not throw a
football are you going to throw at the
combine no those decisions are to be
determined you know I haven't talked
with my team about it too much to be
honest yet we won on January 13th we
celebrated for a week I rested for a
week at home and now I'm here so wait we
those decisions will be made do you
think anybody's ever said that to me in
response to that question I'm sure they
have the company line and I will tell
you what that answer usually means
no we'll see okay but I'm getting a will
see from you let's see what about it
you're protei I will throw out the pro
so you're definitely gonna throw that
photo at the pro day all right and what
will you run at the combine for sure
those decisions will be made with my
[Laughter]
decisions with your team I think the
decisions have already been made but
obviously you know getting in there and
getting on the grease board and doing
all of that stuff and the medical is
gonna be important but that's what I do
that's what I do best
get on the board like what you know I'm
I'm a schematic sky like I said I've I
pride myself in my preparation I win the
game on on Monday Tuesday and Wednesday
by knowing what they're gonna do before
they go before they do it so that's
that's what I'm really good at okay
before I let you go and before we talk
about vault 20 t-bolts 24 by Gatorade I
have a few questions about Cincinnati
that you might have to know if it's true
or false you're from Athens right yeah
it's a three-hour drive from Cincinnati
right two and a half well with a lead
foot yeah pretty much
okay I've got four aspects of Cincinnati
and I want to know if you're already
ready to figure out about this city just
I'm just picking that city out of the
blue yeah okay true or false Cincinnati
true or false with Jobar everybody true
or false
it's the birthplace of Academy
award-winning director Steven Spielberg
false is that true or false it's true
all right that's number one you got to
walk me through this to dawn play-doh
was invented in Cincinnati true or false
I'm gonna go out on a limb and say all
these that you're saying is true okay
it is true now just hold on a second
just because you can read a defense
doesn't mean that you can read right now
this pre-snap Cincinnati is the site of
the United States biggest celebration of
Oktoberfest that's true okay you see did
you do that right then in there and all
about the parties yeah have you been to
an Oktoberfest are you have to talk
about it with your team first let's talk
about with your team and the number one
radio station in Cincinnati is WKRP that
one I have no idea before it's done it's
false
there's a famous TV show called WKRP in
Cincinnati that is way before your time
if you never heard of it at all I'm
older than most college college football
players but I'm not that old I mean we
heard you're older than Lamar Jackson
yeah he was in my recruiting class okay
couple couple months I think and if you
had one choice of a meal would you pick
crawfish or spaghetti with chili
crawfish really I don't like I don't
like I don't like all the Cincinnati
cuisine as far as all that's not yet
great great I might learn to like it but
we'll see okay very good and you can
wash it down with some bolt 24 right by
catering how did you like that segue no
that's good Joe yeah what do you think
of what what do you what do you got here
in front of me bowl 24 is the the
off-the-field drink for for Gatorade and
Gatorade is the on-the-field drink so
both 24 is for recovery it's got
antioxidants elect electrolytes sea salt
and I'm super excited to be partnering
partnering with them yeah both 24 is
again with athletes drink off the field
visit drink bolts 24 calm to learn more
about all that all right I'm gonna ask
you this question one more time and you
can keep if you can give me the answer
and your best a tours or on invitation I
would okay Joe bar oh here we go
you you know I I can't count on any of
my hands the amount of times I've been
asked to give a kocho impression okay so
even though it might make me seem
conventional and I think that I'm
against convention I'm gonna ask this
question of you and see if you can give
me your best coach Oh embarrass nation
are you going to throw at the combine go
Tigers
there's a gentleman Joe Perot everybody
good to see Joe borrow here on the Rich
Eisen show at Joe underscore borrow 10
on both Twitter and Instagram good luck
to you man Boucher thank God don't go
anywhere
we are back still to come on this show
predictions we're gonna actually give it
I want your guys predictions to
Superbowl 53 that's how we're rolling
here on the rich awesome show for more
of the Rich Eisen show tune - audience
Channel 239 on DirecTV for free on BR
live or download the Rich Eisen show app